c'est l'unique oasis sur la xoom en
chalain une épicerie station essence ou
automobilistes et habitants du coin
peuvent se ravitailler
mais voilà quatre-vingt dix ans après
son ouverture le oasis va peut-être se
tarir
jean claude et christine les
propriétaires à trois mois de la
retraite ne trouve pas de successeur
c'est pas évident de trouver des
repreneurs puisque ça demande quand même
beaucoup de travail faut être motivé et
puis
on attend encore d'espoir mais bon ça
s'amenuisent avec le temps ça fait 30
ans qu'on devrait bien ici elle a connu
le père et le grand père de jean-claude
qui tenait avant lui les piscines
comme de nombreux habitants elles
redoutent cette fermeture alors on va
tout est bien embêté je pense parce
qu'il y en a plus rien à la commune plus
de pistes rip boulangerie a déjà rien là
c'est notre point de base
je ne dis pas qu'on fait tout notre
course sans faute au nez mais ce n'est
pas tout bien une personne âgée
notamment de ma voisine s'inquiètent de
savoir comment elle va faire appel à ne
pas y être des personnes âgées dans
c'est vrai que c'est embêtant
du côté de la mairie aussi on s'inquiète
sans commerce
c'est la mort du bourg c'est aussi pour
les jeunes qui arrivent
comment un critère de choix d'une
habitation
on a en ce moment cinq maisons qui sont
en train de se construire sur le village
est une des premières questions c'est ce
qui est une école
et est-ce qu'il ya un commerce jean
claude et christine ne désespère pas de
vendre le magasin est bien situé il ya
du passage pour les intéressés ça fera
deux cent trente mille euros de la
motivation et de l'huile de coude
demain je permets de côté aussi